brynn is a belgian shepherd dog
and an expert tracker thanks to her nose
she specializes in tortoises
brynn and her minder vicky hudson work
for cape nature
a government organization that monitors
rural reserves in south africa's western
cape province
so we're trying to look for the
geometric tortoise the most endangered
tortoise in south africa and possibly
also in the world
it's very difficult to find it's
camouflaged really well and it's
very shy so any disturbance and it hides
itself away very very well
so visually it's difficult to find but
we use the dog
who's got a sense of smell as an
additional tool to find these tortoises
because as they're moving they leave
ascent
the species are rare indeed so rare that
even brynn has
trouble sniffing out a specimen the
encroachment of highways
is just one of many threats to their
survival
finally she manages to find a tortoise
amid all the vegetation
her dedication was not in vain
geometric tortoise is currently being
upgraded by the iucn guidelines to
critically endangered
due to their very small population size
as well as the threat to the habitat
so the habitat fragmentation and habitat
loss are the two major
threats to the tortoise
the population of geometric tortoises is
estimated to now have fallen below the 1
000 mark
worldwide where cape nature comes in
is buying up land through the help of
sponsors to preserve the habitat of the
tortoises
the last of their species
for bryn and vicky today only turns up
one success story
not far away vicki's colleague tony
marshall surveys the consequences
of one of the bushfires that plagued the
region
this fire destroyed the vegetation on
half the mountain
the basically three reasons for the
increase in the number fires
it's burgeoning populations there's a
lot more people close to the vegetation
there's a lot more alien vegetation
around which is making higher fuel loads
and then of course the climate seems to
be getting hotter and drier
which results in more fires
but to combat that threat of bushfires
cape nature has firefighters on call
and inaction around the clock
firefighters in the working fire
basically follow the three
aspects that we look at with the whole
integrated fire management
it's fire prevention which is awareness
raising community
um counselling uh going into the
communities and
and educating or informing the people
the protect the protection aspect is
looking at fire breaks which these
people are
presently doing uh to prevent fires and
the fire suppression aspect is actually
going out when the fire does occur
the group's conservation efforts also
mean jobs for local people
the firefighters get quality training
meaning they can later work for public
fire brigades
they also gain a lot of insights about
the nature around them
you see it comes out easy now i see
differently because
i've learned a lot from kid nature from
walking on fire and
every time there's new things that comes
up
like in nature i've learned about the
trees the kind of trees that
we have here in our environment and it's
seen
things that i didn't know before the
cape floristic region is one of the
biological wonders of the world
it's home to nine thousand plant species
more than a tropical rainforest
and the majority can only be found here
for tony marshall
protecting this treasure is a labor of
love
if for whatever reason this habitat
should be destroyed or get lost
the world would definitely be a poorer
place
and it warrants and needs urgent
conservation
which is why cape nature tries to
recruit farmers such as tom turner to
their cause
he has a vineyard but also fields that
he no longer uses
intensively
cape nature persuaded him to leave part
of his land to nature
yes um so you guys are over here
yep
for the farmer it's a win-win situation
we basically reuse our asset of wildlife
instead of farming with cattle and sheep
that you sell them only when they
are going to the markets we do game
drives
and tourism product which we reutilize
our product by taking photographs of
them
the stewardship program has been very
beneficial
kerry purnell is very pleased with how
the program is progressing
with private landowners now a key player
in the country's conservation efforts
eighty percent of threatened ecosystems
in south africa belong to
private land owners so we really need to
get them on board so we can expand our
protected areas in the western cape
um we have 102 science church of
contracts in the last 12 years
and the program's doing really well
and with further stewardships to be
assigned in the future the result is a
growing network of private and public
nature reserves
where the flora and fauna of the western
cape will finally have the space they
need to survive
you